you
you're looking at Boston where the
nation's first regularly published
newspaper was launched way back in 1704
after that many Americans learn what was
happening in the world after their
newspaper landed in their garden or
driveway in fact many Americans still
get it that way one former paperboy
preserved years of historic headlines
and now he's giving them away to
strangers chip Reid is at the White
House where there is never a shortage of
news chip good morning I think for the
third time this morning I think so but
I've lost count well I tell you we were
there when a crowd of people descended
on the home of a Washington area man who
had a basement full of historic
newspapers including this one Thursday
October 5th 1933 Toledo Blade over here
British speaker denounces Hitler a very
early story on Adolf Hitler now this
gentleman couldn't find anybody who
would take the whole collection not even
libraries so he decided to just put them
out front of his house for anybody who
wanted them fittingly at the foot of his
driveway this former paperboy shared
treasures here we go he waited decades
to deliver nearly a century of history
government lawyer Greg Weinman kept
packed and stacked in the back of his
basement
each meticulously wrapped plastic bag
its own time capsule in all more than
2,000 yellow riddle broadsheets
immortalizing events that changed
America
from Dallas Texas the flash apparently
official the world
[Music]
the earliest editions he inherited from
his grandfather starting with his about
12 he would save major headlines much to
his mother's chagrin and dismay
Wineman continued the collection sharing
the passion with his own children
sometimes I would even go to the airport
back in the pre 9/11 days and wait for
the flight to come in from say Houston
and then pick up papers people had as
they were coming off the plane but this
newspaperman faced his own deadline
downsizing to a condo these old friends
couldn't come along museums and
libraries said no so he did the
unthinkable and decided to just give
them away first-come first-served one
Sunday in his driveway
it is like letting my children go and
for hours people did come with boxes and
babies looking to lay their hands on
history under attack 9/11 oh my god some
hunting for headlines they'd lived
through I was actually there in st.
Peter's Square when the Pope was shot
Wow
so now I had the full connection of even
having the paper others for headlines
from a bit before their time 1926 that's
before you were born right yeah requiem
for a Beatle there is there we go
everything welcome and by day's end come
take everything from before 1990 went
use it in good health
and what didn't the old paperboy took
here for one final toss are you feeling
emotional about all this a little bit I
have to admit there was a moment or two
earlier and I thought I should keep that
I should say that and then I realized no
I I shouldn't say that it's time to let
it go no I'm gonna let go we asked
Weinman if he might have an irresistible
urge to start collecting them again in
his new condo he said no he's taking
care of that problem because he no
longer subscribes to a newspaper the end
what a great what a great story Josh but
I see why he threw him away but on the
other hand you think you can't let them
go but you're saving them for what well
I love that so many people came I did
that's that's great you know we talked
about the technology
getting your news on a phone newspaper
is an amazing technology dispatches from
around the world put them on a piece of
paper print them out they put them on
trunks and and little boys Norman your
guard it's an amazing thing it's a such
a snapshot of a moment it was also fun
to hear I'm always referred to as a
paperboy